well they say play to your strengths and
maybe DC has finally learned that trying
to be Marvel is not one of their
strengths so Geoff Johns came out and
basically said exactly what I was really
hoping DC and Warner Brothers would do
which is that he said that following
Justice League they're basically going
to be de-emphasizing the importance of
the connectivity of the film's now he
kind of he didn't go so far as say
they're abandoning the Cinematic
Universe but there's definitely gonna be
a lot less emphasis on it why well I'd
say that's a really easy call there most
critically successful universally
praised and made way more money with a
much less marketing push then say BBS or
Suicide Squad had was Wonder Woman and
that one has the loosest connections the
fewest tie-ins to the overall franchise
and I'm hoping that they're realizing
that one of the things that was damaging
to some of their other properties
definitely in the case of Batman V
Superman was that in trying to balance
building a bigger universe and telling a
story they sacrificed a lot of the story
and trying to build a bigger and bigger
universe I mean do we have to remember
how insanely awkward and crammed in
literally having one of your characters
open up a little media file with with
like three back-to-back teasers of
movies that are supposed to happen later
so in my mind this is a good thing
because if DC movies are gonna start
succeeding at all they need to be their
own thing and I don't just mean in terms
of tone because I know the people who
have chosen to favor DC over Marvel have
been saying the whole time
DC is doing its own thing except it
hasn't been it's been doing its own
thing tone wise taking a decidedly
different feel to what Marvel is doing
but as far as to what they were trying
to do the bigger picture they were
trying to do the same thing they were
trying to build a cinematic universe
they had their eye on something bigger
than just bringing these characters to
life and that didn't serve them well I
mean if I
not to overpraise the guy but basically
DC never had a Kevin Feige in terms of
someone with their eyes on this who
understood the plan and was overseeing
it theoretically Geoff Johns had that
role but I really feel like the the rest
of Warner Brothers added an entity never
got out of his way if he ever had the
qualifications to do it at all which he
very well might have but I really feel
like Warner Brothers the top executives
never took their hands off this thing so
they didn't have someone who to oversee
it that they were gonna trust to do it
so without that they really needed to
scrap it again they're not scrappy
entirely but they really need to get off
this big shared universe kick and that
appears to be exactly what they're doing
and that my mind wonderful thing because
now we can focus on getting really good
individual films get building really
good franchises around specific
characters and not getting hung up on
how is this going to tie into the next
Justice League movie does this introduce
things that we can then spin off let
just tell a good story just focus and
again even if you liked Batman V
Superman you cannot with a straight face
tell me that it was 100% focused on its
narrative you can see the stitches where
all these things were put in strictly
for the purposes of rushing the building
of a bigger universe and setting up
stuff that is supposed to pay off later
so even if you like the core narrative
there's still a bunch of stuff there
that is completely vestigial to the main
story being told so they need to get off
all of that and I really do think we
have the success of Wonder Woman to
thank for this because that movie had
fantastic legs at the box office in
terms of just going and going and going
week over week over week it didn't open
as big as the other movies but it had
much less drop-off audiences liked it
better the critics liked it better and
don't don't shout at me over audiences
love BBS and Suicide Squad they they
didn't they more of them liked it then
the critics did I'll give you that but
it was even amongst fans incredibly
divisive both those films Wonder Woman
really wasn't that's not me saying
Wonder Woman's perfect either it's not a
perfect film there are people do
like it but let's just let me talk in
the broad-strokes here because the these
are the truths so I will be curious to
see if the people who have already been
on board with DC up to this point are
going to laud this as a good move or a
bad move because for me as someone who
likes DC characters but has not been
enjoying the DC extended cinematic
universe I think this is a great move so
I'm curious and I haven't checked really
in terms of what the reaction from
people who actually were backing the
cinematic universe think about that do
they do they consider this to be a
defeat do they think of this as DC
throwing in the towel I don't know but I
I DC has the potential and has always
had the potential to make better
individual films than Marvel will do and
I honestly believe that the Dark Knight
is better than any individual film that
Marvel has put out but Marvel has built
a much better cohesive functioning
cinematic universe that is Marvel
strengths that at this point because
looking at individual films I don't
think they've made a bad movie they've
had some bad Netflix shows but I don't
think Marvel has made a bad movie but
even their best films are really fun
popcorn movies but most of them don't
stay with you too much longer and that's
not necessarily Christmas and that's
again I'm just stating what I feel is
very much the fact and I love Marvel
I've been really enjoying it
but it is the way that the individual
pieces build to a bigger whole and
Marvel really has created something
greater than the sum of its parts
whereas DC honestly has individual
pieces and I'm talking more about the
core characters that they have to work
with that I think are by and large
better than the pieces Marvel has to
work with but I think it's been shown at
this point that for whatever reason I'm
gonna blame the just the studio
structure of Warner Brothers but for
whatever reason they haven't been able
to fit those pieces into a bigger hole
so the best thing to do is to let those
pieces all shine on there
which will truly allow DC to be
legitimately doing its own thing for
once finally doing this they can say
we're not just chasing Marvel because
they kind of said that before but did
anybody really believe it but now they
can truly be said to be doing their own
thing and and i additionally beyond just
the move the moves not a huge shock
given a lot of stuff we've heard up to
this point we've heard that the batman
movie is being treated as a standalone
not out of continuity but not a not
deliberately building to a next film we
are we know about the Joker movie that
is going on which supposes you got to
have a completely different person
playing the Joker it's got to be
completely out of continuity so all the
indications were there that this was the
move I do like that they've actually
codified it and made it official so that
there there doesn't have to be the petty
fanboy argument of their abandoning the
cinematic universe no they're not David
said they are no again not flat-out
abandoning but there de-emphasizing it
and this will hopefully free up the
resources and the talent and just the
effort to be put into the individual
films because I think Batman Superman
and Wonder Woman demonstrably already
these are characters that are greater
and more impactful than I think anything
marvel's gotten it's stable I mean and I
and on a personal level I do like a lot
of Marvel characters more I love
spider-man i adore characters like
she-hulk and Squirrel Girl but even if
they got movies I don't think that they
could reach the height of something like
The Dark Knight something like the
Richard Donner Superman these characters
are true icons and what can be done with
them if they are truly properly focused
on and not seen as a cog in the machine
but allowed to shine on their own is I
think at a higher level potentially
especially if DC goes back to what it
was doing prior to trying to force
everything into a cinematic universe
which was getting auteur visionary
directors and then basically leaving
them alone things have gotten out there
worse
with the DC films the more involved that
Warner Brothers have been we saw that
back with the Batman stuff because Joel
Schumacher coming in that was Warner
Brothers move and that's not me saying
Batman Returns was brilliant accident a
lot of problem with Batman Returns but
you can see how the switch in tone and
feel everything was a complete knee-jerk
studio move and then you know there's
Man of Steel which again I don't
particularly love but did feel like more
of somebody's vision when Batman V
Superman I can see Snyder's fingerprints
on it
but so much of what is shoved in there
feels like it was studio mandated
Suicide Squad we know the story of that
production what a mess that was they get
somebody like David a or who has the
skill set who has the ambition who has
the talent and the vision they give him
of this incredibly short time to work
with they take the movie away from him
in the Edit Warner Brothers the studio
needs to back off and I think that if
they're no longer trying to build a
grander Cinematic Universe they might be
willing to do that at the very least
with some of these things some of the
more ancillary properties because I'd be
well I I would like to think that if
they're not trying to cram it in and
make sure it fits into this bigger
monstrosity that wasn't working that
they'll leave Joss Whedon alone to make
Batgirl that they'll leave
Chris McKay alone to make Nightwing and
I think that the best version of those
projects is going to be the one with the
studio's more or less leave them alone
and oddly enough this is kind of how
I've always felt about Marvel as a
comics line versus DC as a comics line I
think that DC has better individual
characters than Marvel does however I
like the overall world feel of Marvel
much more than I do DC and that's not me
saying one is definitively better this
is just my own personal assessment but I
am now sort of feeling like maybe the
film's then those franchises are got to
settle into a similar place where Marvel
has you know this big sort of sandbox
playground that I kind of just enjoyed
dwelling in whereas DC has individual
characters that I feel are are on their
own
stronger as individuals and if the if
the film series can settle into that
similar dynamic that I think the comic
books have already been doing for a
while um that works for me
because it'll give me two distinctly
different flavors of superheroes as
opposed to DC trying to do what Marvel
did but just make sure that the tone was
completely different and yeah and that
and that especially didn't work in that
case because it was a tone that it
turned out a fair amount of the audience
didn't want but when you decide that's
the tone of your entire universe it
doesn't free you up to do individual
franchises that break from it where as
Wonder Woman was the one that was very
differently of a different tone and they
let it be that because it was a prequel
it didn't have to mesh quite as much
with the tone in the field so what does
this mean in the more immediate sense
well I mean Justice League at this point
is gonna be whatever it is Aquaman hard
to say but because that's that's already
in production as well I would be curious
to see if the flash movie still is flash
point because flash point really only
makes sense as a story if you are
working in a larger cinematic universe
or as I previously theorized using it as
a way to reset or correct that universe
but if they're just gonna do emphasize
the shared universe at all I have to
wonder if they're so gonna do flashpoint
as a storyline because now it seems like
it's not necessary if you're just going
to disregard the the DC EU when it
doesn't suit your needs and again that's
a move I support I mean that that's how
we got Logan Logan doesn't fit into
x-men continuity properly if you really
try if you really want to be tight and
nitpicky about it but they said who
cares this is the best story and that's
what I want to see Warner Brothers in DC
start doing get somebody who cares about
the characters let them make the best I
mean you know make sure you get a pitch
from them make sure it is not completely
out of whack with what they with what
makes sense for the character but then
let them do whatever makes the best
story to heck with how well it fits with
anything else so I consider this a good
move what are your thoughts on DC eud
emphasizing the extended universe
portion
that acronym whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]